is there a right that you feel like
women don't have in 2022
i mean some rights have been taken away
and it depends what country you go to
and you know obviously in america
they've just you know stopped
abortion
and before in saudi women couldn't women
couldn't drive
and you know in some cultures when we
can't get this sorry i'm talking about
i'm talking about the west in the west
oh i mean just because we're in london
so yeah
yeah you know i mean i would say oh
look by looking in you would say we've
got all the rights we need however if
you even look into because obviously
london is very diverse so you even go
into the cultures things like that like
you look at um child marriages
and um young young women that are fought
into those things these are still that
already got changed recently
to say 18 years should be getting
married so there's still some work on
the ground to do in regards to women and
their rights but definitely in the west
women are set
are saturated with their rights
would you mean this this where they've
got too much rats they've got loads that
loads many rights i wasn't too many
they've just got loads of fights i would
say it's too many because you know it's
it's the privilege that we have been in
the west compared to
other countries that have that privilege
so i can't say too many but i could i
could definitely say
if you live in the west as a female in
some in some cultures you will feel like
you've got a voice where you can you can
talk but then
i think i think we have more rights than
man
but then you know but i also feel like
back to the question of men
a lot of industries are dominated by men
in this country mm-hmm so
why
ah why
what do you mean i don't know why well
you think if you had to think about it
yeah why would you think that those
industries are dominated by men i think
because we live in a patriarchal society
where men are taught i honestly do i
feel like i feel by default okay so then
how are we in a patriarchy when there's
quotas that are specifically for women
that are encouraged to go in those
fields and not men and there aren't
quotas for men to go in female dominated
fields is this in the uk
everywhere
so so there's quotas say for like female
engineers where companies will say you
have to hire a certain amount of
engineers but say in the modeling
industry there's no quota for men
there's no equal pay for men or let's
say nursing
what men women yes women get paid more
in this and i'm saying women there are
more women in the nursing field than men
oh so but there's no quotas for men but
there's special privileges granted to
women in male dominated fields why is
that if it's a patriarchy quotas for men
but there's more quotas for like
maybe black men
i don't even i don't know well like
affirmative action you mean yeah that
but i would
i think um reason the reason is because
when it's been dominated by men
now they have now because of all the
um equal rights and women go to work
what have you they have to navigate the
quota but the quote is never going to be
more than the than the members
but dominated by men what which which
give me an example of a industry an
industry there that you say that's
dominated by men
television in in what sense what
presenting and stuff no like um like
cameraman dops sound
you very really found a sound the sound
engineer you very really really get a
camera
a camerawoman so you think so so i since
i since i work you know this isn't
television it's youtube right but like i
don't find girls want to do those jobs
so like i i've i have ish and i have two
backup producers of ish isn't here
and they're all men and it's not because
i was seeking out like i didn't care i
just wanted someone that was you that
would do a good job and that's who
showed up so why is that a patriarchy if
they if a man and a woman has an equal
opportunity at that job and there's just
more men that want to do it audio sucks
i hate do you think women are not
afforded the the opportunities
that men are in these kind of fields is
that what it is
well obviously um i would say to some
it's to some respect i would say
yes but like if you're an employer the
way i say if you're an employer and you
need to employ a man or a woman more
likely you're going to think as a woman
she's going to want to get married have
kids one day she might you know she's
going to have hormones in balance all
those kind of things you're probably
going to go for an easy option with a
who is a man rather than a woman i think
and those things come into play and what
women are trying to say in those things
that don't look at those things
treatment equals a man and give the best
person the job but as an employer i
understand that you want so so that's
not
but i'm saying like i employ people and
i don't care i haven't played no but and
i'm saying and i'm saying and do you
care
um
when i when i savannah restaurant i did
care because i understood that it's
12-hour shifts
i need someone that's not going to tell
me that kid's sick do not me so i
employed certain people men mm-hmm is
that you part of the patriarchy yeah
because i was a female i've quickly
learned
i had to have a lot more females because
i listened to me more than the men so
then even what i wanted changed around
trying to train around me anyway and
that's what i noticed from working and
employing people
and
and so forth but again i think maybe you
don't i don't care because now and what
i do now because i'm i'm a woman and i'm
blessed i want the best place for the
job so i'm looking at all different
kinds of diverse people whereas i don't
necessarily think some sets of um people
are looking diverse because
like that but i'm saying like i like my
dad my dad employed 250 people and he
like i'm telling you people don't care
as long as we make money i'm trying i'm
trying to get the cheapest employee that
will do the most amount of work that's
that's my goal
and so
and so it's like
like because if you don't do it that way
if you're not hiring based off of skills
then your competition competition's
going to out-compete you
i don't think we employ it by skills
though no but also equal opportunity
doesn't mean equal outcome do you know
what i mean so it's like if we employed
or if we if men and women
they've done it in the um in the
scandinavian countries they've said okay
cool this is the most egalitarian
countries we can find
men and women can go into all of the
fields then we are not we won't restrict
them and what happens is women and men
tend to choose different things which is
so when you're talking about all these
industries are um dominated by men it's
because men choose differently from
women and women choose differently for
men generally when it comes to jobs like
in the stem field science technology
engineering and mathematics men are more
likely to choose those fields whereas
women have the opportunity to go into
those so there's no one's stopping women
from going into those fields
they just don't choose those fields and
where and where are the marches about
the equality of workplace deaths men do
most of the hard jobs plumbing
electricity all of the jobs where you
you can die on the job more men do it
and so they're they're the majority of
suicides they're the majority of
workplace deaths but no one cares
because they see men as expendable
all they care about is the one percent
jobs like do you want to be a fireman
like do women genuinely want to run into
burning buildings and help people no
but do they want to help people a
different way women will come become
midwives
but it's interesting because even in
this conversation like when we talk
about inequality it's always about the
women and no one cares about the man
yeah so what did jordan peterson say
over 90 percent of bricklayers are men
why are we not looking for equality in
bricklaying
oh my god there's too many men in
bricklaying girls you need to start we
need to start getting the female
quarters in women don't want to lay
bricks
that's it
it's that simple
but i also do feel it i also feel like i
think it's also based on what you're
exposed to as well so if you're exposed
to a certain amount of jobs like a lot
of my friends were told just to become a
nurse to be a midwife that was it from
like from young and that's what they
fought to go into until they exposed
other things i think also
you're the way you're nurtured plays a
big part and i think
a lot of uh
girls and boys when young they're kind
of told what jobs you you should or
shouldn't do i think and i think that
kind of buys into it but i i think it's
more biological so i'm one of ten i have
10 siblings actually five boys and five
girls
and all the boys are engineers
i was never told what i could and
couldn't do i just was like engineering
that sounds terrible i think i want to
be an engineer girls typically pick pick
jobs with people
where men pick jobs with things
and yeah and when you pick jobs with
things you get paid more
to what you were saying about
you know the shortage of um camera
people and all the technical side it
relates more to the things rather than
people because
most guys
well i'd say not all i can speak for all
most want to do the people side of the
media
i mean even the people's side is still
not that
the best most women in in tv is plus
management because it's always
organizing
that's what you're trying there's a lot
of things there's a lot of presenters a
lot of presenters are
women
the people that are actually in front
talking to people and things like that
those those a lot of them are women from
what i can see anyway
but there are like some sports that
aren't necessarily offered to women so i
can't remember who i was listening to
sports sports sports sports so like
for instance um i was listening to a
female rugby player
um i don't remember her name right now
but she was mentioning that in school
she wasn't and she grew up in the uk she
wasn't offered the opportunity to play
rugby
and so she was just pushed into let's
say
more female sports like netball so she
didn't actually have the opportunity
yeah but you know what schools that tend
to be offered rugby tends to be more
private schools and grammar schools that
is true so
well and and honestly like i'm a i'm i'm
i play three sports in college and you
know i've looked at getting contracts
overseas and i think it's completely
fair that men get paid more at sports
and that they have more opportunity in
sports because as a business owner
you're trying to make money
and like who can name a wnba player
outside of brittany griner
i didn't watch it but what the women's
world cup is on at the moment right
is it getting the same coverage yeah as
as men's because
people gen don't care about football as
much as well but that's like from
childhood that's what i'm trying to say
it's not childhood i'm saying like we're
not as good and so even at schools if
there's more
if if there's more men's sports teams
it's probably because they could sell
more men's ticket to pay to pay for the
program because it's not free
like you have to pay the coaches you
have to pay the people the referees you
have to pay the people
to run the games
and so it's like if you're going to have
a program something has to pay for it
and i think it isn't it free in the uk
though like well nothing's out of the
taxes
i'm saying nothing i'm saying nothing's
free so even even if it comes from like
government money you still have to
decide what to do with it and what has
the biggest roi i don't think the
government should
um
basically allow everyone to have the
same opportunity so
so you know encourage women to play
rugby if they want to do women generally
trying to get battered and bruised on
the field yeah i don't think some women
do yes obviously but women generally
don't want to get battered and bruised
on the field you know what i think it's
more i don't think it's about okay so
yeah a lot of women don't want to do the
nurturing they'll say the bricklaying
jobs and all that high level labor will
get hit whatever but i think it's more
of a case of if someone does want to do
that mm-hmm can the opportu opportunity
be there i think that's the problem i
think in times past it's been a case of
when women have want to do certain
things
it hasn't
when they have gone the door's been
knocked back do not mean it's not so
that's a case of all women because not
the women are happy to just do what
they're doing live their life but a lot
of i think a lot of men get knocked back
as well so i don't think you can you can
necessarily say it's just women
it's it's the best person you have to go
in there with a with a mindset that i'm
gonna get this and you have to be
competent to make sure you can get it
like it men get knocked back all the
time when it comes to roles jobs and so
on and so forth because there's another
guy there that's just better
yeah
if there was if there was enough women
actually asking to want to do it i'm
sure that they would like get little
girls how are they supposed to know
we've been in school but i'm saying like
why are we going to push it on them do
you really think it's natural for that
woman do you really think that women
playing rugby is natural
like just genuinely like just
come on do you think it's unnatural yes
yes i want to play so you think there's
something wrong i don't think the
question was do you think it's natural
like naturally women want to do that or
do they naturally not that it's
unnatural to do it no no i'm saying do
women naturally want to play rugby do
you think there's a long line of women
just dying to play rugby
where they get there yeah
they want to get bad and but if they're
all brought together from different
parts and like at least as an
opportunity then i'm saying if they
they're a minority yeah you're right
yeah and i'm saying like why are we
trying to push it on them we're not
pushing it we're just making it
available at the same level as it is for
men because that's what okay so i'll
give you a similar equivalent i'll give
you i'll give you a similar equivalent
at my college we had a lacrosse team
because it had to be equal there's like
title nine in the us
and they would bag girls to play
lacrosse like that like they were
recruiting me so hard i did like two
practices i was like nah skiing and so
it's like why are they pushing that on
it if girls don't want to do it
it's like you're putting like their
agenda on on women instead of what women
want to do naturally
right so what happens if there's the
minority that do want to do it
is there opportunities for them to do it
i'm not saying they should be paid the
same because i do agree it's a business
it needs to make money
but i'm just saying at least at school
let them be trained because this woman
had she missed 18 years of her life you
know she only had the opportunity when
she was 19 which delayed her a lot she
could have been a lot better at her
sport if there was at least an
opportunity i mean i think if there's a
large group of women that want to do it
sure but for one girl
like come on pick a different sport like
i'm sorry
like i'm an athlete right okay and there
were sports that weren't offered at my
school and i just picked a different one
i didn't go on tv and cry about it like
like boo freaking who we live would you
mean we don't have a synchronization
we live in the richest society in all of
human history like our lives are so good
and you're gonna [ __ ] because you
weren't offered freaking rugby when you
were nine if there weren't people that
did that like we would still be let's
say like some countries in the middle
east like
obviously there's some women that had to
say oh hang on i want to drive and then
things change so i want to return that
i'm like done driving